можна будь-яким чином намагатися змінити
ситуацію в державному резерві але поки
будуть такі випадки як місяць тому коли
на закупівлі тушонки хотіли нагріти
державу на 50 млн грн то можна приймати
все що завгодно воно буде до одного
місця і те що зараз відбувається з
тендерами останній час воно свідчить про
те що О сатаніли вже в намаганні
обкрасти державу вже до краю Я дуже
добре розумію чому Верховна Рада не
захотіла включити мене в тимчасову
слідчу комісію яка буде розслідування
проводити питання тендерів Я особисто
чув як мотовиловець всій своїй фракції
давав вказівку не голосувати голосувати
проти мене а тому що я постійно зараз
пишу про ті тендери про розтрати про
марнотратство про корупцію про від
крадівництво яке відбувається зараз е-е
з державного з місцевих бюджетів те що
сьогодні замість того щоб купувати дрони
і все що потрібно для збройних сил
України мільярди гривень ідуть на е-е
ремонти доріг місцевого значення в
Житомирській області сьогодні Вінницькій
області 700 млн грн оприлюднили угоду то
це ясна річ що буде ставити питання і я
і народ України до вас і повірте мені я
буду далі писати про те що зараз
робиться з державними коштами і коштами
місцевих бюджетів можете не пускати мене
в тимчасове слідчу комісія буде туди
приходити але люди потім спитають з вас
що ви Тут робили поки була війна і
скільки ви накрали безсовісно накрали